Welcome back! Let's connect the dots. We
started with the technical issues in the
structure of an operating system for a
single CPU, then a parallel machine, then a
distributed system. We saw how object technology
with it's innate concepts of inheritance and
reuse helps in structuring operating systems at
different levels. Now, we go one step further.
How do we structure the system software for
a large scale distributed system service? It's too
limiting to call it an operating system. Large
scale distributed service. As we continue this lesson,
we'll get a glimpse of how object technology
has gone ballistic to provide the services that
you're reliant on for your everyday internet e-commerce
experience. In this lesson, we will describe enterprise java
beans and the term java bean is used to
signify reusable software components. That is many objects, java objects,
in a bundle so that it can be passed
around easily from one application to another application for reuse.